I wrote a piece yesterday about the
sexual revolution kind of a follow up 50
years later checking in I mean how did
that work out had all that go didn't
work out very well it turns out and I
was prompted to write about this because
of a story out of California where STD
rates are at record highs among young
adults according to a new report and the
STD epidemic is very serious across the
nation so this story was pretty familiar
at this point and we could go down the
list of what the sexual revolution
brought to us STD is that's just one
part of the problem I don't say that the
sexual revolution created or or invented
STDs you had them beforehand
but we are seeing STD epidemics and
certain certain diseases are at record
highs now and that's not a coincidence
now we know what the sexual revolution
promised to bring us promise to bring us
free love and happiness and pleasure and
all that what did it actually bring us
well
STDs when we talk about STDs let's start
with AIDS okay
the AIDS epidemic swept America right on
the heels of the sexual revolution and
that is not coincidental
you know you had the hippies with their
free love and everything and then boom
we have AIDS okay and then now we have
epidemics of gonorrhea syphilis
chlamydia across the nation what else if
you look at a if you look at a chart of
the divorce rate it's very interesting
and I would recommend that you do that
just to try to fact-check me here don't
do it now but after the video
Podcast go go look at a chart of the
divorce rate starting in like 1890 and
what you're gonna find is that there is
it is steadily inclining all along it's
a steady gradual incline which tells you
that these problems didn't you know they
didn't start yesterday they didn't start
with a sexual revolution our cultural
problems go back much further than that
but if you look 1890 through you know
the the early part of the 20th century
just a steady divorce rates still low
steady incline you get to World War Two
and there's a brief sudden spike which
coincides with a brief sudden spike in
the marriage rate and then a plummets
back down again
and it starts that gradual incline and
then right around the 60s 70s 80s that's
when it just explodes there is an
explosion of divorce and it stays
extremely high for a while now it has
recently been trending back down again
it's still very very high but the
divorce rate has been declining again
and people will point to that and
they'll say oh okay well well you know I
guess that that spike in the divorce
rate was an anomaly and we're kind of
figuring things out not really because
what you'll notice is that the incline
in divorce is also coinciding with a
drastic drop in the marriage rate so
Millennials are giving up on marriage
completely
they're just cohabitating instead but
many Millennials have replaced marriage
with collaboration the average age of
first marriage for men now is 30
compared to in 1950 it would have been
for four I know for women it was like 24
for men it was probably around 23 24 now
that is a that is a is a very high no
that's a that's a very big difference
between those two so average age of
first marriage has gone way up and there
are many Millennials so I've just given
up on marriage I think something like 20
to 25 percent will never get married
so the next step is kind of underway as
we speak
divorce was merely the the spike in the
divorce rate the explosion of divorce
was just the first consequence of our
enlightened sexual attitudes the next
step which is happening now is the
dissolution of marriage as an
institution so divorce was endemic for
my parents generation the generation
that started the sexual revolution and
now in my generation and these are the
kids who were raised by all these
divorced parents they're just throwing
up their hands and they're bailing on
marriage and they're saying I don't need
it
again that's not a coincidence
you have this kind of domino effect
that began with the explosion the
divorce rate on the heels of sexual
revolution which destroyed a whole
generation of families and then and then
it it completely soured another
generation to the whole idea of marriage
and so what's going to happen with the
generation after this
it's not good what else what else did
this Africa sexual revolution give us
well lots of dead children 60 million
dead children through abortion and
Counting then we have the spike in unwed
pregnancies which we have to distinguish
from teen pregnancies that's another
objection I've heard people have said
well the teenage pregnancy is go is down
it's it's it's it's teenage pregnancy
it's less common now than it used to be
well yeah that's because you know your
grandparents and your great-grandparents
their generation yeah teenagers were
getting pregnant but you but guess what
those teenagers were married so the teen
pregnancy rate doesn't mean anything at
all there's nothing wrong with an 18
year old being pregnant if she's married
and that's how it used to be as I said
the average age of first marriage in the
40s and 50s for women was 20 which means
that a whole lot of a millions were
getting married when they were teenagers
it was very common throughout human
history for women to get married young
so that's not the problem the problem is
unwed pregnancy
it's a in a a married 18 year old woman
who was pregnant is in a much better
situation than a 35 year old single
woman who is pregnant so we have the
spiking in unwed pregnancies we have the
obviously the problem of porn addiction
fatherless homes on and on and on
it even ruined our university system
which has turned into this embarrassing
orgy of drunkenness and debauchery which
it was never meant to be but that's what
it's become now
and why why did it have this result
goes back to what we were talking about
yesterday
sex is a powerful thing and there are
two there are two things that happen
when you're reckless and frivolous with
sex and you remove it from the bonds of
marriage like we discussed yesterday and
this is what sexual revolution was all
about taking sex removing it from
marriage and then what happens is number
one you lose the deeper joy that can be
found in sex you've you've settled for
mere pleasure which was already a part
of the joy okay that was already a part
of the bargain but the joy something
that you experienced through the
intimacy with someone who you are
committed to and you love and you're
devoted to and you have you know what it
is happening within the safe confines of
the marital Union that's how you
experience the deeper joy in that
intimacy
now we've lost the joy you still have
the physical pleasure but you haven't
gained anything because as I said the
pleasure was already part of the joy all
you've done is you've loot you've lost
something which is the joy second you
still have to deal with the consequences
of the power of sex sex is a powerful
thing and you still have to deal with
those consequences except you're going
to be unprepared for those consequences
because you aren't married
and thus the consequences are worse
you
so the the quote old way was to save sex
for the confines of committed marriage
because it's the safest context for it
this is really the only form of safe sex
that you can have you hear a lot today
about safe sex and it's just absurd I
mean it really is ridiculous that we're
telling sixteen-year-old high school
students that it's possible for them to
have safe sex with some with you know
some classmate of theirs if they use a
contraceptive that that's not it's still
not safe as is clearly evidenced by all
the things I just listed off everyone's
having safe sex now yet we're having all
these problems so clearly there's a
disconnect here it's still not safe
still isn't say that there's still many
potential consequences that cannot that
cannot all be solved or prevented by
contraception it's kind of like telling
somebody that
it's kind of like if we invented some
sort of special helmet and harnessing
system for a vehicle that you can use so
that you can safely drive drunk
it's like saying to kids well listen
it's best if you don't drive drunk but
if you're gonna drive drunk
well here's this special helmet and
special seatbelt make sure to use that
now I don't want you to but I know that
you kid then you're gonna do it so just
make sure you do it safely
there's no safe way to do it it is by
nature a reckless act when you've got
unmarried high school students who are
reckless and frivolous and dumb and
they're going around having sex with
each other well there's no it's right
there's no safe way to do it it doesn't
exist
here's so you know you've got these the
two potential options save it for
marriage don't save it for marriage and
the question the equation kind of works
like this yeah you know it's like you
have to ask yourself okay here is this
act of sex this act and it requires you
to fully expose yourself to another
person and to be completely vulnerable
through them it can bring great pleasure
but it can also be an effective means to
transmit awful and deadly diseases so it
can do both at the same time
um and also you may you're not gonna
know if the other person has a disease
unless they tell you and a lot of times
they don't want to tell you it will
likely cause you to feel an emotional
attachment to this other person or else
if you do it with the wrong person in
the wrong context it may cause you to
feel a deep disgust with yourself and a
shame and oh by the way this act can
make babies as well I mean it can do
that
now the question should you do it with a
stranger
everything I just listed fully expose
yourself completely vulnerable offering
yourself up can transmit disease
involves your emotions can make babies
before we even talk about what this act
is pretend you had no idea about human
biology and I just explained it to you
that way which is completely accurate
and then I say you know whatever this
thing is do you think it's something you
should do with a stranger
we used to say no of course not
obviously not
but with the sexual revolution we said
yeah sure what could go wrong
well a lot could go wrong
and did go wrong
now some people have argued with me and
they they point out that
the world was not a bastion of sexual
morality before the 60s there was rape
there was disease there was prostitution
there was lust there was promiscuity all
throughout human history the sexual
revolution didn't invent any of that
that's what I've heard over and over and
over again over the last day
and this is the argument that you hear
anytime you talk about the moral decay
in our culture there are always people
who try to rationalize it to try to
dismiss it they try to dismiss it they
try to undermine the importance of what
you're talking about by saying well this
is how things always have been and yet
it's true
that this kind of stuff has always
happened it hasn't always been as bad as
it is now
now that would be completely false
because what you have now now they've
always been promiscuous people lustful
people there's always been prostitution
there's always been people having sex
outside of marriage there's always been
adultery all the stuff what you have now
is that all of those things are a
completely mainstream they're entirely
in the mainstream they're not out on the
fringes they're not seen as this fringe
gross shadowy shameful thing that you
have to slink off to a dark corner of
society to engage him that's how it used
to be and yet people were engaging in it
in those dark corners but now it's just
out in the open why is that because
there's a really crucial difference
between you know how it is now with
these things and how it used to be
people used to do these things
yet society and the individuals who did
the things still knew that it was wrong
to be lustful to be unfaithful to be
promiscuity promiscuous was seen as
shameful and wrong and dirty which
didn't prevent anyone from acting that
way but it did mean that our although it
was a it was a disincentive
I'm sure it convinced a lot of people to
not act that way
but no matter how you know no matter how
effective it was in terms of preventing
it did mean that our basic moral compass
was still preserved the acts themselves
didn't change but what changed is our
attitude about those acts and because
our attitude changed that means that
these things are even more common now
now it's one thing for someone to you
know for someone to do something evil
and admit that it's evil and be shamed
by society for the evil
but it's another thing for him to insist
that the evil thing is actually good and
then for society to agree and throw him
a parade
celebrating
society can survive when people do bad
things because people have always done
bad things but society cannot survive
when people are celebrated for doing the
bad things
so that is a really important difference
it's a hugely important difference
it is it's the difference between a
thriving growing prosperous healthy
civilization and a civilization that is
collapsing
now another argument is that a lot of
these things as I just touched on
touched on earlier but a lot of these
things divorce certain STDs unwed
pregnancy some of these things are on on
a downward trend again and that's true
but all that means is that they exploded
as a result of the sexual revolution and
society has since been struggling to
kind of contain the damage so going back
to the explosion in divorce on the heels
of sexual revolution started to decline
again part of that is there was this
catastrophic result of this horrible
thing called the sexual revolution and
Society has now just been has been it
has been trying to catch up and find
some way to contain this it has made
some progress in containing some of the
damage but the problem remains and
you know we still have the fact is we
still have damage to contain
and at what cost has the damage been
condemned
well as I said the divorce rate is down
largely because the younger generations
aren't getting married so that's been
the cost for getting the divorce rate
down the cost is discouraging marriage
altogether
teens today are actually less sexually
active according to you know different
reports and studies that you'll read
teens today are less sexually active
than they were in years past and even in
the last you know they would have been
20 years ago or 30 but that's largely
because they're inside
their computers
and a lot of the sexual activity has
migrated online
and I'm not sure if we're placing in
person promiscuity with online
promiscuity is really an improvement I'm
not sure that it is
it's probably more of a lateral move it
may actually be a step backwards because
it's less human
I mean you've got
on one hand you consider a teenager
who's 16 and has sex with his girlfriend
which is not good and not advised
on the other hand you have a teenager
who's 16 and isn't even attempting to go
that route because he's just watching
four hours of porn a day instead
and he's kind of getting his fill that
way
we're supposed to believe that there's
been some kind of improvement because
teens are you know going going with the
with the with the latter approach but
I'm not sure that it's really better not
sure the hours of porn today are better
than that in-person experience as I said
at least it's lateral
it may be worse actually
it may easily be worse because there's
this dehumanizing that goes on with
pornography
reducing of another human being to just
nothing but an image on a screen for you
to consume
um
so not sure that's an improvement I mean
not it's certainly not is not an
improvement at all
now the final argument people have made
against my point is that is that I
haven't offered a solution which first
of all I you know I kind of think it's
that's a sort of a lazy way around when
somebody is observing and pointing out
problems in our culture especially
problems that a lot of us refuse to face
and admit our problems which is what I'm
trying to do here so when someone does
that and then you come in and say well
there's no reason to talk about it
unless you offer solutions we got to be
solution oriented
give me a five-step plan to solve the
problem and I know that's supposed to
sound very practical and logical it's
actually lazy it's a it's kind of a lazy
cowardly way around the observations
that the person is making it's a way for
you to not engage the observations that
the person is making because yeah
obviously I can't sit here right now and
solve society for you okay I can't do it
neither can you and if that's the if
that's the the price of entry into this
conversation is that we have to come
equipped with a with a three-step
solution to solve all the ills of
mankind well that means that we should
never talk about anything ever again
because none of us have that solution
all right
so no I don't you know in fact I think
it's it's gotten so bad and
we're at a point in our societal
collapse where I'm not sure that there
is any solution
I'm not sure that it can be solved I'm
not sure that we can be pulled back from
the break at this point I'm not sure
that we can
I can I can look throughout history I
can find many civilizations that have
gotten to the point of course ancient
Rome is a great example I could find
many civilizations that have gotten to
the point where we are now I'm not aware
of any that ever got to that point and
then did a 180 and turn back and what
they are the direction and save
themselves I'm not sure of that ever
happening
so we may be at the past the point of no
return I don't know
what I do have a solution actually on an
individual level I can't do anything
about I don't know about on a collective
level I can't force anyone to adopt this
solution but the solution is actually
pretty simple it's a solution that I
offered yesterday it's a very simple
solution but it is a solution to almost
all these problems I have just mentioned
and that is to get married stay married
be faithful in Mahna and monogamous
that's it that's the that's the solution
so that's your that's that those are the
steps get married stay married be
faithful
that's a 3-step plan there we go
married stay married faithful do you
want a three-step plan I tell you what
if everybody did that
as an alternative if everyone adopted
that approach as an alternative to the
modern sexual revolution approach
almost all these problems would go away
they'd be gone
they would not be problems anymore if
everyone actually did that
now I know that everyone is not going to
actually do that
so this solution is not gonna solve the
problem because it's not going to be
adopted but if it were
that would solve a lot of our problems
just like and this course is related so
many of our societal problems would be
all but solved overnight
if we got rid of the fatherless issue
and dads just stayed home with their
kids
the state stayed home with their
families and didn't leave
that also would solve a lot of our
problems
if we had intact families and marriages
and if people prioritized their families
and their marriages and if they saved
sexual activity for the confines of
marriage I'm not saying we would live in
a utopia but we would certainly live in
a society that doesn't have to deal with
hardly any of this stuff
if you want a solution aside from that
well I can't give you one today because
it doesn't exist so basically we do that
or there's no solution and we just plumb
it into our civilizational demise those
really are the two options there is not
a third one so it's up to us to decide I
think I have a pretty good idea of which
one we're gonna we're gonna choose
unfortunately but
we can always pray and hope
and prayer
that's another big part of the solution
thanks for
listening have a great day Godspeed